the point of prototypes is to be seen
and interacted with but who should be
seeing one of the most powerful concepts
in answering this question is the idea
of circles of feedback loosely defined
there are four of them first you have
the product team as well as other people
within your company or social circle
these people are very easy to find and
interact with but are too close to the
project to give accurate feedback as a
customer they're ideal for low fidelity
prototypes second you have subject
matter experts these are people who know
something about the market in which the
product will be deployed but are not
working on the product with you they are
also good for low fidelity prototypes
and can give you decent insight into
medium fidelity prototypes third are
your customers these are people who are
in your target market and who you could
reasonably expect to want your app they
give great feedback once the prototype
is of a fidelity they can actually
interact with and are perfect from
medium and high fidelity prototypes the
last circle only applies to some apps
but is really vital for those apps these
are your customers customers they are
really important to get feedback from
and are perfect for the same types of
prototypes as the customers are let's
look at an example to identify circles
of feedback pretend for a moment that I
was just making a service for college
students to do their reading and turn in
their homework assignments now it's
possible that I'm doing this project on
my own but even then it's likely that I
can find a friend or co-worker who has
gone through the college process that
friend is someone I could walk through
the app and would be in this first
circle of feedback the second circle
would be experts in the field in this
case that would be college professors
educational theorists or UX designers
third would be the college
administrators does the prototype fit
their needs as people who would actually
pay for the app they would be the
customers finally we'd want to show
medium and high fidelity prototypes to
college students themselves these
students are customers customers and if
they don't like the app colleges will
not buy it from us so it's always
important to test with all four circles
of feedback again this last circle only
applies to some apps
but is really vital for those apps